[APPLAUSE]
DR. STEVE JONES: Thanks.
I see that pile of books has
gratifyingly disappeared.
I'm happy to sign them
if you want me to.
But I should warn you that the
unsigned ones are at a premium,
because they're so rare.
OK, good.
My book is about science
in the French Revolution.
And it's got quite a
lot of science in it.
But it's also got a lot of stuff
which I didn't know at all when
I started, which is the way
in which scientists actually
were engaged both before
and during the revolution
in the political events and
the way in which many of them
paid a very severe penalty,
including the death
penalty for their engagement.
And that's what I want to kind
of talk through in this talk.
This first cover
shows-- actually,
it's a British cartoon.
It's by Gilray, the famous
18th century cartoonist,
which shows scientists
being attacked by the mob
and thrown to the mob.
OK?
They're trying to climb
up this pillar to escape.
But they're being
thrown to the mob.
And many of them indeed
were thrown to the mob.
And you can see in
that image-- you
can see the scientific
instruments coming down.
You can see a balloon
in the background.
Of course, it was the
age of ballooning.
You see some surveying tools.
And as you'll see,
it was the age
of the great survey of France.
And so that's the
theme of the book.
Now, in fact, the first
time I went to Paris,
I start the book by
saying, the first time
I went to Paris,
very coincidentally,
was in May 1968.
And I was on my
way to the Pyrenees
where I spent many
years going every summer
and working on the
genetics of snails.
As I often say, I'm one of
the world's top six experts
on the genetics of snails,
and the other five agree.
But that's no longer true.
I don't think there's the
six of us left anymore.
I believe the other
two agree now.
But I was on my way down there.
And I had never been
to Paris before.
And I'd come from Edinburgh.
We're talking 1968, which in
Edinburgh was 1958 effectively.
And I got to Gare du Nord.
I was amazed by
the bright sunlight
and the busyness of the scene.
I got on the train.
I got on the metro
to get to the station
to go down to the south.
And when I was on the metro
train, I noticed an odd scent.
And I thought it was a perfume.
It was pungent.
It wasn't unpleasant.
And it wasn't until I opened
the newspapers the next day
that, in fact, I discovered
it was tear gas seeping
into the metro from the
riots which had started on
that day or the day
before just above.
So that was my
introduction to France.
And here we have the famous
image "Souis les Paves la
Plage"-- "Under the
Cobblestones of the Beach."
Well, they pulled up
plenty of cobblestones.
But they didn't find
the beach, I'm afraid.
And that always reminds me
of Marx's great statement
that history always
repeats itself.
The first time is tragedy.
And the second time is farce.
And the farce, I think, was this
was the [FRENCH] revolution,
which really went nowhere,
except it generated lots
of hippies most of
whom are now my age
and are still grumbling
about revolution.
But the tragedy-- it was
a tragedy in many ways--
was the French
Revolution itself in 1789
and the great disasters
and wars which followed it.
As I've said, many
of those triumphs
and the tragedies
of the revolution
were motivated by science
and by scientists.
In fact, the very moment
of the revolution,
every Frenchman knows, is
called the Tennis Court Oath.
And this is a painting
by the French painter
David of a gentleman
with white hair
standing and
addressing the crowd.
And this was the moment when
the left wing, as we call them
today, split away from the
endless discussions with Louis
XVI, and went into
the tennis court,
and declared that there was
going to be a revolution.
And in time, there
would be a republic.
And the person who
led that was actually
an astronomer, Jean
Sylvain Bailly who
later became mayor of Paris.
And he was actually
quite a good mayor.
Here he is-- Bailly , the first
mayor of revolutionary Paris.
He still did astronomy.
He looked at the
transits of Venus.
He was quite popular in spite
of this rather unkind cartoon.
But unfortunately,
there was a riot in 1791
where his troops shot
down a number of rioters
on the Champs de Mars, which
is where the Eiffel Tower now
stands.
And poor Bailly was the first of
many scientists to be executed.
And he was actually guillotined.
Now, in fact, Bailly was
one of many scientists
who believed that there were
scientific laws of progress
in human affairs.
And many of them thought
that a revolution was
inevitable in the
same way as there
were laws of physics which
could predict the future,
then there were scientific laws
of society, which would predict
the future of human affairs.
And here's just a few of
them-- the politics of science.
Lamarck, the famous
biologist-- "There
is an urge to improve in life."
De Tracy, who was a
physiologist and an expert
on the visual system,
invented a word
which has become quite
widespread-- ideology.
He invented that word, and
he said, as you can see,
"Ideology is part of zoology."
Condorcet was a mathematician.
He was murdered in prison.
"The laws that the
direct the Universe
are necessary and constant.
Why should this be any
less true for those
with the intellectual and
moral faculties of man?"
And Bailly, who was guillotined,
"The universal language
of science will open
the golden age."
And in fact, that notion still
pervades the French education
system.
Condorcet set up what became
the modern French high school
education system, which is,
although it's rather rigid,
is fairly effective.
And every French 17-year-old has
to pass an exam in philosophy.
Here is this year's question.
De Tocqueville wrote
that, "Dogmatic beliefs
are more or less numerous
according to the times."
Others say, "no dogmatic
beliefs, opinions
that men receive in
complete confidence
and without debate"-- Discuss.
I'd like to give that to a
bunch of British 17-year-olds
and see how they got on with it.
I think the answer
would be not very well.
So this kind of large
view of the Universe
and a philosophy being important
is certainly very much alive
today.
So in 1889, the anniversary
of the revolution,
there was a contest as
to what the French should
do to celebrate the centenary
of that great event.
And they wanted to
build a monument.
There were various
entries-- one of which
was a 300-meter tall model of a
guillotine that didn't actually
win, fortunately.
But what did win
was this here, which
is of course, the Eiffel Tower.
Now, the Eiffel
Tower-- that's it
pictured in 1789--
the Eiffel Tower
was for 40 years, the tallest
building in the world.
And it was built by an
engineer, Gustav Eiffel,
who already had built a number
of railway bridges, which
are magnificent things
in their own rights,
built out of wrought iron.
And his technique was not to
build a bridge with huge steel
girders that fought
off the wind,
but to build lightweight
structures which allowed
the wind to blow through.
And the Eiffel Tower
is a remarkable place.
It's 300 meters high.
It's very light.
The weight of the air within
the bounds of the Eiffel Tower
is less than the weight
of the wrought iron used
to construct it.
There are 18,000 girders there.
And the base is 125
meters on every side.
And if you were to melt down all
the metal in the Eiffel Tower
and fill the base with it, it
would be 6 centimeters deep.
That's all.
So it's a very, very
sophisticated structure indeed.
It was very unpopular
when it first appeared.
The novelist Guy de
Maupassant insisted
on having lunch in its
restaurant every day,
or so he claimed, as that was
the only place in Paris where
he couldn't see
the Eiffel Tower.
Still, however, it's now
of course very popular.
And it's just celebrated
his 250 millionth visitor.
Now, Eiffel only had a 20
year lease on the site.
But he had a plan,
which was to turn it
into a scientific
observatory and a laboratory.
And he did that
with great success.
He did a number of observations.
For example, he was he
was an aerodynamicist
as one might imagine,
and he did a number
of experiments of dropping
heavy weights on wires
from the top-- weights of
different size and shape--
measuring how fast they moved.
And from then on,
he went on to build
the world's first functional
wind tunnel, which
is at the base of
the Eiffel Tower,
and was used for some of
the very early experiments
on aircraft wings.
So he did all that.
So it was a working laboratory.
It was the site of the
first ever radio broadcast.
And that became
very useful in 1914,
because the area on
the top of the tower
picked up a message from
the German Army, which
was advancing on
Paris, and the troops
were sent out in taxis,
without tipping them very well,
to get out and stop the army.
And that was the
Battle of the Marne.
So there's plenty
of science that
went on in the Eiffel Tower.
But if you stand
on the Eiffel Tower
and you survey the
beautiful view of Paris,
and I kind of do
this in the preface,
you see all kinds of
sites around which
are actually monuments to
Paris as the city of science.
Now, you can go on an
artistic tour of Paris.
You can go on a
revolutionary tour of Paris.
You can go on an
architectural tour of Paris.
But as far as I know, there
are no scientific tours
of the great sights
in Paris, which
are of scientific importance.
But there are dozens of them.
I'll just talk about a few.
Here is a famous experiment
that never actually happened.
This is Benjamin
Franklin's kite experiment
where he's supposed to have
held a kite in a thunderstorm
with a wet string and a key.
If it had been struck, he would
certainly have been killed.
There's no question of it.
So he didn't do the experiment.
But he wrote a book
in which he mentioned
that kind of experiment.
It was called "Experiments
on Electricity
Done in Philadelphia."
And that book was
read by Louis XV.
That was the last
but one monarch.
And he was very
interested in it.
And he told some
of his researchers
to test out some of the ideas.
And here's the world's first
lightning conductor in Marly,
which is on the West of Paris.
And what they did was
to put, you can see,
you can put a metal spike up.
And they paid an unfortunate
volunteer, a dragoon,
to hold a metal baton close
to the spike and sure enough,
great streams of sparks
moved between the two.
And that was the world's first
lightning conductor in Paris,
not, in fact, in Philadelphia.
Here is the world's
first measurement
of the speed of light.
That too was done in Paris.
It was done by a
guy called Fizeau
who transmitted a powerful
beam from his laboratory
to a mirror on the top of
the hill of Montmartre.
And the beam shot out
and came back again.
And in front of
the returning beam,
he spanned a wheel
with conchs on it.
And as the wheel sped up,
suddenly at one moment,
the returning light
was blocked, which
meant that the cog had come
into place at just the moment
the right of return.
And you could work out the
speed of light from that.
100 years before, people might
imagined the speed of light
had actually been measured.
And it was remarkably accurate.
So that's a physics experiment.
Here's the Luxembourg Gardens.
Had you gone in the
year of the revolution,
you would have seen
only purple flowers.
And those flowers are, in fact,
the flowers of the potato.
And one of the things
the revolutionaries did
with the help of a
guy called Parmantier
was to introduce the
potato as food into France.
It hadn't been
used as human food.
It had only been
used as animal food.
But Parmantier, with a
great deal of difficulty,
persuaded people to eat it.
People didn't like
to eat the potatoes.
First of all, it's not
mentioned in the Bible.
So you don't really want
to eat something which
isn't mentioned in the Bible.
Secondly, it grows
on underground,
which is inconveniently
close to hell.
And thirdly, there are all kinds
of strange beliefs about it.
There's a line in Shakespeare's
"Merry Wives of Windsor," which
Shakespearean scholars
have long puzzled over,
which Falstaff is there.
And he persuaded himself
that he's persuaded two women
to share his bed.
And he raises his
eyes to the heavens.
And he says, let the
sky rain potatoes.
What does that mean?
That turns on the belief, in
Shakespeare's time and later,
that potatoes were
actually aphrodisiacs.
I have to tell you, I've
eaten lots of potatoes.
I've never really
noticed any real effect.
But another aspect
was the first survey
of France-- first triangulation
of any country, which set up
the metric system--
the meter, which
is 10 millionth of the
distance between the North Pole
and the Equator measured
through Paris and the kilogram,
which is a cubic
decimeter of water.
So that too was done
at just after-- one
of the first acts of the
revolution was to set that out.
But the Eiffel Tower itself
records much of that.
And there are the names of
many scientists, 72 to them,
on the tower.
Here we see, for
example, we see Ampere.
And most of all, we see
somebody call Lavoisier.
And the rest of my
talk is going to be
devoted Lavoisier,
who was really
the founder of modern chemistry.
He was the discoverer,
or the co-discoverer,
of nitrogen, oxygen,
and hydrogen.
But however, he was
very much involved
in pre-revolutionary and
post-revolutionary politics.
And in fact, his
fate gives my book
its title, because
he was dragged
in 1793 before the
tribunal, which
sentenced many people to death.
Quite why that happened
I'll explain in a moment.
He was sentenced to death.
And somebody very bravely
shouted from the back
of the room, you
cannot kill that man.
He is a genius.
And the judge said,
the revolution
has no need for geniuses.
That's the title of the book
and the fate of the revolution.
So why did people
hate him so much?
They hated him because before
he became a great scientist,
he'd actually been what's called
a tax farmer-- somebody who
bought the right to collect
taxes from the French state--
went out and they
agreed to a sum.
They went out.
And anything they could
collect above that sum,
they kept for themselves.
And that led to enormous abuse.
We have exactly the
same system today,
of course, with
PFIs on hospitals,
for example, where it cost 40
pounds to change a light bulb.
So in the end, the hospital
costs four or five times
as much as it should have done.
So the system is still
around, although it's actually
disguised in a slightly
nontransparent way.
So here is Lavoisier.
He was a philosophe, or a
scientist we call them now,
who paid the price.
And here's a cartoon of him
being carried by his farmers
to extract taxes from the poor.
And if you didn't pay your
taxes, you were in trouble.
You went to prison.
If your really insisted,
you'd be hanged.
There were riots.
People paid all kinds of taxes.
And the one they really
hated most of all
was called the octroi.
And this was the tax which is
paid, particularly in Paris,
by all the goods that
came into the city.
All the basics of life-- salt,
bread, wine-- had to pay a tax.
And in order to
gather this tax, there
was a wall around
Paris, which you
were supposed to pass
through and pay the tax.
But in Lavoisier's time,
that was very leaky.
It could, for example, just
be a terrace of houses.
So all you need
to do was to bring
in something from the
back door and take it out
of the front door.
And you wouldn't
have to pay the tax.
So Lavoisier built a wall.
And this is the 1784 wall.
It's the dotted line.
And there's a fragment of
it, which is still there.
You can see it wouldn't
be an easy thing
to get over let alone
carrying a barrel of wine.
And he built the wall.
And in it were a number
of collection points,
a number of tax
offices, which you
had to pass through and pay.
And people hated this.
And in fact, on
the 13th of July,
1789, the first act
of the revolution
was to storm Lavoisier's
wall and burn down
most of the entry points.
And there are only
two of them now left.
And the following
day was, of course,
the siege of the Bastille.
And that's when the
revolution really got going.
But it was the wall that
really sparked it off.
So the Bastille just
freed only four prisoners.
There were only four
prisoners in there.
But it was the moment which
the French now remember.
So Lavoisier was is kind of
forgotten as a politician.
But he's very much
remembered as a scientist.
And this is another
painting by David, which
is in the Met in New York.
It's a wonderful painting.
It's said to be the best
painting of glass ever made--
different textures
and colors of glass.
His wife helped him
greatly in his experiments,
as we'll see in a moment.
And Lavoisier did many,
many striking experiments.
Here is one.
This is Lavoisier's is famous
burning glass experiment.
He invented really the idea
of elements-- particles
which couldn't be
broken down any further.
He got rid of the
idea of phlogiston
that somehow there
was a substance
in every chemical, which
when it was burned, was lost.
He got rid of the
idea altogether.
This is a very
clever experiment.
What he did was to make
a big double burning
glass outside the Louvre and put
a diamond at the focus, which
is what he's doing now.
And when it was opened and
the sun streamed through it,
of course, the
diamond disappeared.
Carbon in its
crystalline form had
been combined with oxygen
to make carbon dioxide,
then it blew away.
And of course this
greatly alarmed
the grand ladies who were
parading through the Luxembourg
Gardens at the time.
But it was a proof of course
that you could combine things
in this way.
And Lavoisier founded
modern chemistry,
but also founded
modern physiology,
as we call it, the modern
study of the workings
of the human body.
And his line was, which it
was radical in that day,
but is quite correct is that
life is chemistry that actually
what happened to the diamond
is what happens to us.
And he did a
respiration experiment.
And here he is in his laboratory
in the back the there.
In the rear there is Madame
Lavoisier taking notes.
He's got a subject
sitting in a chair.
You can see him.
His name was Seguin.
And Seguin has got a mask on.
And he's breathing in oxygen,
which is being generated,
and breathing out
carbon dioxide.
And indeed, Lavoisier was
able to work out that there
was a balance between the two.
Then they made Seguin exercise
on a thing that looked a bit
like a stationary bicycle.
It pulled up a heavy weight.
And then his metabolic rate,
as we would say today, went up.
They measured the amount
of heat generated.
Lavoisier invented
the calorimeter,
which an apparatus with ice in
it into which he put a guinea
pig-- the first person to
use a guinea pig in biology--
put a guinea pig and measured
the respiration of the guinea
pig and measured the
amount of heat involved.
So he published his results
in the year of the revolution.
"The animal machine is
governed by three times
the regulator's-- respiration,"
which involves oxygen
and carbon and furnishes
heat, digestion,
replenishes that which
is lost in the lungs,
and transpiration that increases
or diminishes in accordance
with the necessity to carry
away more or less heat.
So life was indeed chemistry.
Now, there's a balance in that
between the amount of exercise
you do and the amount of
energy and oxygen you need,
which I'll return
to in a moment.
I'll just mention
another unexpected fact.
This is Jean-Paul
Marat, who led one
of the vicious
groups of the post
revolutionary years
the group in fact
which the prosecution in
the end executed Lavoisier.
And Marat is famous for
having been a politician.
He died stabbed in his
bath by Charlotte Corday.
But before he was a
politician, he was a scientist.
And he actually
lived in Britain.
Here we have a reprint
of two tracts--
one "An Essay on Gleets."
Gleets, as we all know, is
nonspecific urethritis ,
or venereal disease.
And Marat was a doctor and
was interested in treating VD.
And actually, was a
rather more successful
than many of the brutal
techniques then used.
And secondly, he was
interested in the eyes.
And he stopped people
using mercury, which they
used to use to treat the eyes.
And actually, Marat got a
degree from the University
of St. Andrews.
All he had to do was to
pay the university do
this, which led Dr.
Johnson, the famous sage,
to say the University of St.
Andrews gets richer by degrees.
And at 9,000 pounds a year.
They're still doing it, at least
the English universities are.
So that as Marat.
Marat's science
was very strange.
He developed a thing called
the solar microscope, which put
sunlight through a microscope.
And he persuaded himself that he
could see, if you had a candle,
you could see phlogiston
or elemental fire
being released by the candle.
So he thought that Lavoisier's
dismissal of phlogiston
was wrong.
And that led him to persecute
the poor old Lavoisier,
and in the end, to kill him.
And here he is being
murdered in his bath.
So all right, that's the
physiology of Lavoisier.
Here's one of the last two
tollgates in the world--
La Ratonde, which is a very
good and very expensive
restaurant on the
Canal Saint-Martin.
I have eaten in it once.
But it was it was too
expensive to go to very often.
If you eat in such places
too frequently, and perhaps
much cheaper places,
what will happen to you?
Your balance in the
Lavoisier equation
will change, because you'll
be taking in too much energy
and not losing it, OK?
And what that has done
in the last 30 years
is lead to an
epidemic of obesity.
And here we have, and
I'll go very quickly
through these-- these are
the figures for people
who are morbidly obese.
And that's really obese in
the United States from 1985
until today.
In 1985, plenty of states
didn't have any data in them.
So they're white.
But the warmth of the color
shows what proportion of people
are morbidly obese.
And only a few states
had more than 10%.
That was 1985.
By 1990, a majority of
states had more than 10%.
By 1995, we are getting some
states-- almost half-- about 1
in 6 are morbidly obese.
By 2000, we're getting plenty
of states where it's 1 in 5.
By 2005, states where we're
getting towards 1 in 3.
By 2010, 1 in 3 or so is common.
And in 2015, we've got plenty
of states where it's more than 1
in 3 are morbidly obese.
So that's a major
health problem.
It's not confined to the states.
It happened in Europe too--
liberte, egalite, obesite.
And what's striking
both in the States
and in Europe, of
course, that we
live in a unique moment
in human history,
because the rich are thin,
and the poor are fat.
And that's a complete reversal
of the historical event.
So that's what happens when
you unbalance the Lavoisier
equation by taking in more
fuel than you are able to burn.
But there's the other
side of the equation
too when you burn more than
you can take in as fuel.
And the Tour de France is an
absolute exemplar of that.
The Tour de France
at the end circled
some of the monuments of
the revolution, of course.
And the Tour de France
began, as only in France,
as a political gesture.
It began in 1903 to do
with the Dreyfus Affair.
And many of you will
know that Dreyfus
was a Jewish French
senior soldier, who
was accused of treason quite
wrongly-- was sentenced
to Devil's Island.
There was a huge row in
France that went on for years.
And the whole country
split over Dreyfus.
In the end, Emile Zola
wrote a bitter editorial.
And Dreyfus was released.
But there had been
a bicycle magazine.
There had been a
bicycle magazine,
and of course, cycling
was getting popular then,
I called "The Velo."
Now, one of the advertisers
in that magazine
was a bitter anti-Semite,
an anti-Dreyfusar.
But that "The Velo"
was pro-Dreyfus.
So the anti-Semite
said, I'm not going
to advertise with you anymore.
I'm going to start my
own magazine which is
going to be called "The Auto."
And the first act
of "The Auto" was
to have a bicycle
tour around France.
And the first one was
enormously challenging.
The first lap went
from Paris to Leon.
And it took 18 hours
nonstop cycling to do it.
Now, from the very beginning,
people began to cheat.
Here's the first cheat
in the Tour de France.
He looks like a
bit of a villain.
And in fact, he took the train.
And they found the train ticket.
But he has some noble fellows.
Here is Lance Armstrong, of
course, who was a major cheat.
And in fact, people now suggest
that the whole of the Tour de
France is an uncontrolled
experiment in pharmacology.
Everybody cheats.
Everybody cheated.
People have died through
taking various drugs.
And quite remarkably,
the man in the iron mask
was the first to
isolate morphine.
Very soon after that,
he isolated strychnine.
And these are the kinds of
drugs that have been widely used
by athletes to try and
improve their performance
or to get rid of pain.
So that's another
time with the history.
Now, it is an
interesting spin on this,
because I'm coming to
the end of the talk
now, because Condorcet,
who I've mentioned already,
the philosopher, was actually
a very forward thinker.
He was a particularly
against the idea
that you could classify
people's rights by biology.
He was very strongly in favor
of women being able to vote,
for example.
And in the end, he
succeeded-- women
could vote-- to "the claim
that any human group is
of its essence less
or more blessed
with particular
abilities is an attempt
to make nature
herself an accomplice
of political inequality."
Well, that's a very
noble sentiment.
But actually, exercise,
physiology, and extreme sport
shows that he was wrong.
And this really has
placed sports, and perhaps
many other things
with a dilemma,
because it turns out that
people of African origin
have different metabolic
patterns than people
of European origin.
These are the overall
obesity of frequencies
in the United States for 2010.
If we just do, and as I
say, the warmer the color,
the higher the proportion
of obese people.
So that's white, black and
Hispanics in this group.
And here we have African
Americans in 2010.
And if you compare
that with the overall,
you'll see there is much more
obesity in African Americans
than in the
population as a whole.
Now, part of that without
doubt is cultural.
It's clear that
African-American are poorer.
They have a worse diet.
They often take less exercise.
And there's more
acceptance of obesity,
it's said, in that
group than others.
But part of it is
in fact biological.
I don't know how well
you can see this,
but these are the genetic risks
towards obesity and diabetes
in Africa versus other
countries in the black line,
to the right there, is
the African frequency.
And it's quite a big effect.
Africans have different
metabolic patterns
for reasons we simply
don't understand from us.
Now, that's a
problem with obesity.
But actually, when you're taking
the other side of the Lavoisier
equation, and you're
exercising like mad,
it's actually a bit of a gift.
Right?
Here is where it
shows it most of all.
Here's the Paris
Marathon-- fifth biggest
in the world-- 42 kilometers.
And it follows the end of the
course of the Tour de France.
And in fact, there's
been a striking shift
in the nature of the world's
top 25 marathon runners.
In the early part of the
century, 50 years ago or so,
almost none came from Africa.
Now almost all of them
come from Africa, OK?
Now, that without
question is partly
a social thing in that if you
win one of these top marathons,
you make a lot of
money and particularly
if you're an African that
maybe wants to buy a farm.
So there's plenty of impetus
from that point of view.
But there's biology
in there as well.
There is a group
called the Kalenjin,
who have an extraordinary
pattern of physiology.
They are super athletes
from the word go.
They live very high up in
the mountains of Kenya.
And they have many
evolved adaptations
to a low oxygen environment.
Most people, most of us, if we
are climbing Everest let's say
and we have low oxygen, your
body does something very odd.
It shuts off the blood supply
to about half the alveoli,
the little absorbing
surfaces in the lung,
to allow the other half
to work efficiently.
However, the Kalenjin
don't have that
so that all the alveoli work,
because they're constantly
under the low oxygen. And
they've adapted to it this way.
And that's quite a big effect.
So they can soak up oxygen
much more efficiently
as well as metabolizing
much more effectively
than Westerners.
They have the mechanical
little advantage
of having very long limbs.
But that's important,
because they can lose heat
very efficiently as well.
And in fact, the Kalenjin
represent 1/2,000th
of the world's population.
But they're one-fifth of
the top marathon runners.
They live at 2,000 meters or so.
Even before they're born,
they're oxygen stressed.
And so they generate more blood
vessels to transport oxygen.
They run from childhood onwards.
Plenty of them run 10 miles to
school and 10 miles back again.
They tolerate higher
body temperatures.
They've got lower
pain sensitivity
and various other
things, which means
they are genetically
predisposed to win
in this kind of operation.
So really, that
idea that we're all
equal in extreme circumstances
in the Lavoisier sense
is clearly wrong.
Now, that doesn't mean to
say the environment isn't
important.
It's not widely known that
Mo Farah, probably the best
athlete in the world, has
an identical twin brother.
Mo came to Britain.
His brother stayed
at home in Somalia
and became a motor mechanic.
Mo tells us that he used
to race his brother.
And half the time he'd win.
And half the time his
brother would win.
But of course now, of course,
Mo would win every time.
The genes haven't changed.
But Mo was trained.
So training is important.
But genes and biology
are important too.
Now, let's just remind ourselves
of what happened to the people,
Lavoisier included, at the
time of the revolution.
These slides, which I'm
going to gallop through,
are the people who were either
imprisoned, or executed,
or murdered at the time of the
revolution, each one of which
was a scientist,
many of whom would
have won Nobel Prizes today.
The ones in black were
merely imprisoned.
The ones in red were killed,
most of them guillotine.
And lots of red splashes
there, and more red splashes,
and a whole pile
more red splashes.
So it wasn't
actually a rare fate
for a scientist to be
executed for his behavior
and his beliefs.
Now, strangely enough,
we have nothing
at all of that on this
side of the channel.
There are almost no
examples of scientists
becoming involved in politics.
However, as we all
remember, there is one.
Here we have a
British scientist,
who became a politician
posing for an election
leaflet in 1951.
And she worked on
saponification.
And saponification,
as many of you know,
is treating oils
with alkali to make
soft soap-- a very appropriate
thing for a politician to do.
And that is of course
Margaret Thatcher.
Now, whether or not she
should have been imprisoned
or be executed, I don't know.
But it's kind of a statement
of how extraordinary
really the world
across the channel
had been in 1789 when scientists
were at the absolute center
of political life.
Now, that's never
happened in Britain.
In many ways I think
we're fortunate in that.
We're quite happy grubbing away
in our own laboratory and our
in front of our own
computer scientists.
And that philosophy
was summarized
by a great predecessor
of Margaret Thatcher.
"Scientists should be
on tap and not on top."
And I'll stop there.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
FEMALE SPEAKER: I
have a question.
What was the most interesting
scientific discovery
that you came across
while writing this book?
DR. STEVE JONES:
The most interesting
scientific discovery?
Well, I think there was a
mathematician, many of you
know, called Laplace,
who was a mathematician
and an astronomer.
And he was the guy who
gave us the mathematics
of the Universe.
He worked out the way in
which the solar system worked.
And he was very
strongly of the opinion
that it was all like a
gigantic clock, a machine.
And Newton, who we
Brits tend to think
was the originator
of modern astronomy,
actually believed that God
had designed the Universe
and spun it into motion.
And it was proof of God's works.
And in fact, Newton
wrote 10 times as much
about the book of
God's words, the Bible,
rather than the book of God's
works, astronomy and gravity.
Laplace solves several problems
that Newton couldn't manage
and persuaded himself that
the whole of the Universe
was ordered and
would be predicted.
And if you knew what
happened on day one,
you could be absolutely certain
of what would happen on day 10
billion and 1.
And that was actually
the philosophy
that was behind the revolution.
When Napoleon, who himself
studied with Laplace,
read Laplace's
extraordinarily dense book,
which is way above my
head, about mathematics.
Napoleon asked
Laplace, why is there
no mention of God in this book?
And Laplace came up
with my favorite phrase,
which is I have no need
of that hypothesis.
You don't need God.
But of course, the startling
discovery we now know
is, of course, that Laplace
was completely wrong.
The Universe is chaotic--
Big Bang, black holes,
all that stuff-- we
can't predict anything.
And amazingly
enough, the discovery
of that chaos--
where was it found?
It was found on the
top of the Eiffel Tower
in 1903 when radiation had been
discovered in Paris, of course,
by the Curies.
And somebody had
the bright idea--
they had a radium source.
And you could measure
it 300 meters away.
The radiation declined
with distance,
as we all know, the
square of the distance.
And somebody had the
bright idea just checking
of going, say, what happens if
we go vertically 300 meters?
And what happens to the
radiation source than?
It turned out it declined.
But it didn't decline enough.
And he suggested,
it was a priest
who did it actually, he
suggested that there was
radiation coming in from space.
And that's where cosmic
rays were discovered
on the top of the Eiffel Tower.
He was laughed out of court.
But he was right on
those cosmic rays
are the crashing and
banging of the chaos
of the Universe,
which is blasting
the Earth at all times.
So that's another
reason why it's worth
visiting the Eiffel Tower.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Do you think that
quote still kind of applies
to British politics
at the moment
considering how
funding potentially
might be going with government
funding and lobbying?
DR. STEVE JONES:
Well, what's very
striking about British
politics at the moment,
depressing though
it is, is there
are no scientists in Parliament.
There was one last time.
A time before, there were two.
Now there's none.
And I think that's unfortunate.
I've forgotten how many lawyers
there are-- 250 or something?
I think we should
be playing a part.
But apparently we're not
interested in playing a part.
It's a difficult problem.
And science funding
is being cut.
But we have to
remember, it's not
being as cut as much as
many other things are too.
And I'm not convinced that
if we were on top that
would make much difference.
The only other revolution where
scientists, or maybe there
are two, where scientists
have played a part
was in the Russian
Revolution, there
was an attempt to
bring scientists in.
But that failed
miserably, because as
soon as the Mensheviks, the
moderates, had been ousted,
then we got all this
stuff like Lysenkoism,
where the politics defined what
the science should be saying.
And that, of course,
doesn't work.
And in the Chinese
Revolution, Chairman Mao
was interested in getting
scientists involved.
And that didn't
really work either.
So I think the observation is
on the three times it's been
tried, it's failed every time.
So I think we
shouldn't try it again.
AUDIENCE: What was it in
Paris at the time which
meant that scientists
became politicians?
You said that didn't
happen in England.
But what was unique about Paris?
DR. STEVE JONES: I think
what did it was actually
quite straightforward.
It was money.
Now, Louis the XIV had
founded the Royal Academy
of Sciences, which had
its home in the Louvre.
And that was just
after 661, which
was when the Royal Society
of London was founded.
But there was a great
difference between the two.
Now, the Royal Society in London
was a private gentleman's club.
And there were great scientists
of astonishing ability
who help found it--
Christopher Wren included,
and Boyle, and all these people.
But they joined the club,
which they paid to belong to.
And I say with a
certain amount of shame
that I actually belong
to the club myself.
And every year I
curse and swear when
I have to pay 150 pounds to
do all this work for the Royal
Society.
Whereas in Paris, it was
the other way around.
What happened in the Royal
Academy of Sciences--
if you were elected to the
Royal Academy of Sciences,
you were paid a very
generous salary.
So of course, that
allowed plenty of people
to spend their lives full
time working on science.
There were no professional
scientists in Britain
really until probably
the 1860s, I would say.
They were all either rich
amateurs like Darwin,
who was extraordinarily
rich, or a few of them
were employed by the Royal
Institution, let's say.
But beyond that, they
were all dilettantes.
Whereas in Paris, they
had this scientific class.
And I think that a
lot to do with it.
AUDIENCE: I was
interested in what
you thought about the balance
between politics and science
and how much scientists
have removed themselves
from politics to
the extent that when
we have, for instance,
medical research, scientists
often now will kind of correct
for confounding factors, which
are probably political.
So they'll say, OK, let's
strip out the effect of this--
this poverty, whatever it is,
and produce recommendations
which are about changes
that the individual can make
that has profound political
effect if all of the scientist
recommendations
are all about what
the things we do that when
we strip out those effects
rather than make perhaps
easier-to-implement
recommendations, which change
the politics that causes
those confounding factors.
DR. STEVE JONES: Yes,
I think you're right.
There's a long and
ignoble history
of science itself being
used, being abused,
to political ends.
RA Fisher, who worked at
University College, London,
who really was, as I'm
sure all of you know,
was a central figure
in the development
of modern statistics.
He spent most of his career
working for the tobacco
industry.
And he was a chain smoker
himself, incidentally,
saying there was no link
between smoking and lung cancer,
because that was correlation
and not causation.
Now, of course, if you want
to wear your Bayesian hat,
he was right, It is a
correlation, not causation.
But the correlation
is so damn strong,
that you really should
take some notice of it.
But the tobacco industry managed
to stay ahead of the game
by appealing to this
great statistician.
So science has been abused.
Scientists make recommendations.
They've made
recommendations about sugar,
for example, which simply shown
no sign of being implemented.
And that obesity epidemic
is much more serious
than the lung cancer
epidemic, because lung cancer
is a great way to go.
You go to your doctor--
got a bit of a cough.
The doctor says, oh, dear, don't
start reading any long books,
because your survival
chances are low.
You're not going
to last very long.
And you're not
going to cost a lot.
With type 2 diabetes, it will
probably kill you in the end.
But it's going to take
15 years of increasingly
expensive treatment.
So it's a real, real problem.
And yet all governments,
almost without exception,
have failed to act on sugar.
Now, people like us--
we're aware of the risks.
And so we behave properly.
But other people aren't.
I've mentioned
Somalia and Mo Farah.
The average male life expectancy
in Britain and Somalia--
in Somalia, it's 28 years
less than in Britain.
And Somalia is a country
torn apart by civil war.
It has famines and the like.
Let's go to Glasgow.
The average life expectancy
in the center of Glasgow,
in what used to be the
Gorbals, is 28 years less
for men than life
expectancy in Lenzie,
which is five miles away,
which is a nice suburb.
So over five miles
in Glasgow, we've
got a mortality slope equivalent
to a poor African country
and a rich European country.
And that's because people
are not being told the truth.
Or maybe they are being told
the truth by scientists,
but the truth is being
disguised from them by people
who want to make money.
So I think really
science can only advise.
I think as long as science
is advisory, then it works.
But once like as
in the revolution,
science thinks it
knows the answer,
because they are the scientists.
Then I think then
you get into trouble.
FEMALE SPEAKER: OK,
thank you professor.
DR. STEVE JONES: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]